hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
in my full motox review video I talked
about why I think this phone gives one
of the best Android experiences of any
Android device out there and this is one
that I'll be recommending to a lot of
people for that reason but there are a
lot of things that I didn't even talk
about in that review video so I figured
I might as well bring a whole bunch of
that stuff over here to this one these
are some things that I've learned from
using the Moto X for a while now and
some things that I've actually done to
my own Moto X so without any further ado
these are some Moto X tips and tricks
now number one is that the Moto X is not
just a black or white phone like a lot
of the other phones out there this is a
totally customizable phone so you
actually be able to choose between
hundreds of different color combinations
for the back color of the front color
and the trim color to really make the
phone your own now this is starting on
80 and slowly moving out to other US
carriers there's also been hints of
international availability later down
the road so keep your fingers crossed
that that's very soon but right now it
is 18 tioman this will all be available
through moto maker comm which is the
site that's actually live starting today
that's where Motorola will let you like
play around with and select the color of
the front back and trim of your Moto X
now the thing is in the store you'll
actually only find the all black or the
all white Moto X because they can't show
every single color combination in the
store so what they'll actually let you
do is go into the store and if you
decide that you want to buy this Moto X
you can buy a car sort of a Redemption
card then go home go to the Moto maker
website and punch in the scratch-off
code on the redemption card and then get
your customized Moto X shipped to you in
four days or less now I'm still trying
to decide what color for myself I would
get for the Moto X right now I'm between
basically these three right here I was
initially just going to do the red and
black because I'm so confident with
those colors but it looks a little bit
pink to me it looks a little bit off red
not quite the same red that I'm used to
and all the other stuff that I usually
do red and black in so let me know which
one you would go with down below or even
better if you play with the Moto maker
site yourself today go ahead and drop on
twitter at mkbhd a picture or a
screenshot of the Moto X that you design
and customized and I'll retweet some of
my favorites over the course of the next
few days so go ahead and play with those
and I'll check out what you guys made
number two is when you first get the
Moto X
or something that I do if basically any
Android phone I get is I have a little
routine that I do with a lot of the
customizations in the settings and my
favorite apps and games that I initially
like to install some of these are
totally predictable and some of these
are kind of weird one of the things I
always do is go into the developer
settings and speed up the animations to
do 0.5 times the time so they're twice
as fast which kind of gives the phone a
much faster feel right out the box and
it gives me an idea of just how well the
GPU can handle that kind of stuff and
then I like to go ahead and install my
favorite apps some of the stuff I've got
going on right now I really like the eye
in the sky app for weather that's pretty
much always the first weather app I
install on the device
I read all my news and feedly now and
something else I've been getting really
into Google Play games side-by-side
multiplayer stuff with some of my
friends on Google Play so that's been
fun but you want to check out what's on
my Android device I'll leave that as the
first link below that like button so you
can check out all the stuff I've got
going on on other Android devices that
views number three now is touchless
control you're going to want to set this
up and at least have it turned on so
that it recognizes your voice because
you might not think you're ever going to
use it but it's actually saved me a
couple times when I've needed to text
someone and my hands are full or I need
to check something and it's hands-free
now it's the technology that allows you
to say ok Google now and that it starts
listening to your voice of course it's
going to try to translate everything and
put it into Google now but the thing is
I mentioned in the review video it's a
little bit slow has a little bit of a
delay in the process but what's neat is
they moved this to being updated through
Google Play now so Motorola isn't going
to have to roll out an entire new
operating system update just to get you
an update to that touchless control like
if there was an update to the skin but
now if there's something a bug they need
a fix or a feature they want to add or
an improvement to the process boom they
just push it through the Play Store and
you got it and before is the battery now
you're already going to get pretty great
battery life out of the box with the
Moto X but there are some specific
things that you can do with the Moto X
then I've learned that you can just
extend the battery a little bit more
with number one it's an AMOLED display
so all the off pixels are going to be
totally black
so using black themed apps and even a
black wallpaper and whatever else you do
on the phone to use more black pixels
those will actually in the end save you
a little bit of battery life not an
extreme amount but it's worth checking
out I also found the auto brightness on
the Moto X to be really aggressive so I
turn
often actually started managing a
brightness manually the display is
always the biggest battery killer so I
just found that I usually have the
brightness on max but whenever I'm
indoors I can bring it down to like 50%
instead of having it ramp up and down
like crazy whenever the lightning
changes number 5 is using the camera now
I've mentioned that the camera is the
most disappointing part of the Moto X
and it still is but you know what it's
got some time to improve there are some
firmware updates that will probably make
it better but before that even happens
there are some things that you can do to
get some better quality at least more
reasonable decent quality out of the
Moto X camera number one is HDR you'll
find that in the camera when you swipe
into the side and get the settings HDR
is on auto by default but what HDR
actually has to do is take multiple
exposures and combine them into one so I
turn that on and off manually basically
you can turn on this high dynamic range
mode when you're taking a picture of a
still object or you're not moving at all
and that will help you get a lot more
bright colors much more vividness more
detail and of course much better dynamic
range but if you're taking any sort of
moving shot turn HDR off it's going to
look terrible also because of the clear
pixel sensor letting in so much more
light you're actually going to get way
faster shutter speeds when HDR is off
and you'll find that you can actually
freeze action way better on the Moto X
and any other phone which is actually
really useful so you can actually take
pictures of like cars moving by and
things like that again turn HDR off
you're going to take pictures of moving
objects but I took a comparison shot
between the Galaxy s4 and the Moto X and
the galaxy s4 took about a 1 mm of the
second exposure and the Moto X took I
think a one over four thousandth of a
second exposure so you're really going
to be able to freeze action when you get
a lot of light in the frame and actually
something I just recently started doing
with my Moto X to make at least my Moto
X camera experience a little bit better
is I started using camera jb+ which is
an app from the Play Store which gives
the stock jellybean camera to any
Android device and since the default
camera app on the Moto X doesn't let you
tap to focus and then recompose before
you shoot I actually found myself using
this app a lot to go ahead and tap to
focus make sure everything is composed
right and then take the picture again
it's instant shutter everything is just
the same way it is on a Nexus device
when you're using this app and actually
prefer that and the images look just as
good they don't degrade the quality of
the images at all so I found myself
using camera jb plus a lot on the Moto X
there's still no fix that we can do on
our side for what I would characterizes
sort of muted colors and an overall
softness to the image but again fingers
crossed that that's just a firmware
update away so that's just a little bit
more for you guys on the Moto X I know a
lot of you guys have already decided if
you want to buy this device or not by
now especially if it becomes available
internationally unlocked a lot of you
guys have already decided whether or not
you want to pick that up but I'm looking
forward to the suggestions you guys
throw for the comments and the colors
and especially the designs you guys make
on Twitter and also I'm this is a good
device for like a first-time Android
user like I've said this is going to be
great for learning a lot of the AOSP
Android tricks like the two fingers
swipe down for the notifications to get
to quick settings the swipe up from the
bottom to get to Google now a lot of
this stuff is going to help first-time
Android users really get themselves into
a new version of Android and on-screen
buttons and the whole edge to edge
display experience it's nice it's pretty
nice I like this phone I guess you could
call it my daily driver I pretty much
never say that on video but I've chosen
this over the HTC one when it comes to
Verizon so thanks for watching hope you
enjoyed again check out the description
below that like button that's where all
the important stuff will be for this
video the review video link the
explained features link the app I talked
about all the other stuff that'll all be
below thank you for watching again and
I'll talk to you guys in the next video